desde hace tres meses más de 2000
familias expulsadas de sus viviendas
debido a la crisis están ocupando
ilegalmente este terreno de un centenar
de hectáreas ubicado en gernika a unos
30 kilómetros de buenos aires con lonas
planchas lo que pudieron encontrar
construyeron casas frágiles la extrema
precariedad de sus condiciones de vida
cohabita con una gran determinación de
salir adelante desde el principio
dividieron la tierra en parcelas iguales
trazaron futuras calles plazas y
escuelas
no hay alcantarillado no hay asfalto ni
agua potable por ahora pero si una
inmensa solidaridad
hoy la unión de trabajadores y
trabajadores de tierra vino a ofrecerles
a los habitantes de gernika 10 toneladas
de verduras producidas por pequeños
agricultores
camila es una de las 7 delegadas de
gernika elegida durante las primeras
asambleas de esta ocupación auto
administrada por mucho más
respuesta en la salida ya buena líberos
atrás mismos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
pero no
corazón
[Aplausos]
con el fin de garantizar una
distribución justa camila toca las
puertas con ayuda de otros para repartir
las cajas a los habitantes de la zona
que supervisa aquí donde paola y sus dos
hijos que estuvieron entre los primeros
en instalarse en estos terrenos en
barbecho desde hace 40 años los
propietarios inversionistas privados
desean desarrollar barrios privados de
lujo
y vine acá porque
estaba pagando alquiler
sin trabajo
en familia
la pandemia no puede trabajar más
cuando escuché que
a cabo una toma
[Música]
todo lo que poseen paola y sus dos hijos
cabe en lo que ella llama su pequeño
cuadrado duermen juntos en un colchón de
una persona aislado de la intemperie por
estas lonas sacudidas por el viento me
duele mucho que la gente piense que
somos criminales porque no lo somos
no nos queda de otra era esto o la calle
con lo que hay a disposición fuego y
agua que les traen sus vecinos paula
prepara una comida comunitaria y
transforma su jardín en sopa popular
para unas 30 personas nos toca nosotros
mañana manzana
así vamos rotando por luisana así todos
los días y comida para todos
a pesar de las condiciones de vida
difíciles cárnica representa una
esperanza para habitantes tales como
gaby la hija de paola
[Música]
la verdad me va a ser muy feliz nos
quedamos porque ya mi mamá no va a tener
que esforzarse en tanto poder pasar más
tiempo con nosotros digamos
2300 parcelas de tierra equivalentes al
mismo número de historias de vida todas
únicas al fondo del terreno ocupado
mónica a su esposo y sus dos hijos aún
no han podido construir su vivienda así
sea precaria sus vecinos le entregan los
postes de su alambrada antes de llegar
aquí vivían en la calle en el centro de
la capital
porque yo iba a un bar para pegarme un
baño y baña a mis hijos allá en
constitución olvida nunca esa gente por
favor
y tienen tienen tele ellos y mire por el
coso por la por la tele y todo me dicen
doña me dice porque no se va para allá
para esa toma me dice ayabaca para que
le regalan un terrenito
mientras esperan poder conseguir el
material necesario para construir su
casa a marcelo prepara una huerta la
tierra para hacer una huertita cosa que
uno sólo tiene en mente hacerlo nada más
que necesita estos lugares para poder
hacerlo perdido porque no me esquina en
esto que le podemos haber uso para
numerosas organizaciones sociales
acompañan la lucha de los habitantes de
gernika hoy fue abierto por primera vez
un espacio dedicado a la infancia un
poco de plastilina y unas 11 para
aportarles algo de despreocupación
es algo importante para las infancias no
es como una de las tareas elementales de
cualquier pibe de cualquier tipo y es un
derecho que también muchas veces en
contextos como este se ve vulnerado no a
pesar de las amenazas de expulsiones de
la justicia y las promesas de
reubicación del gobierno quienes han
encontrado refugio en gernika tratan de
construir una nueva vida que esperan sea
mejor